hey there in Conan O'Brien here I'm in
Chicago at the moment on tour with one
of my favorite comics Taylor Thomas in a
Taylor hey likely wave that's nice
it's very kind of little fashion yeah it
is you know Taylor a hilarious comedian
this is the second leg of the tour come
on with us you're doing a great job
and one of the things I love most about
doing this is I'm hanging out like in
fans and in airports learning about
these comics these people and you were
telling us a little bit about your life
in the van the other day growing up sort
of the stuff that you were obsessed with
when you were a kid yes well we're right
near an American Girl doll store right
now and I being the only 25 year old
girl in the band is the only one who
knows what that is
everyone thought they were only dolls
there are books there are films great
films but how many films are there the
American girl I mean I think there's
only like three I think but you've seen
them oh I've seen them yeah this one is
the Samantha one okay great for
Christmastime annasophia robb really
nails it okay I would go for that one I
know they made a Mollie want Old Spice
some ice just felt for building almost
killing a woman but it's all fine I
don't want to see actual murder on
camera so so you were really into these
oh yeah really into a super into and you
were into the dolls too but but here's
we get to the sad part of the story the
tailor revealed in the van tell me the
sad part sad part is so I got the
catalogs where you could look at all the
stuff you could get for the dolls you
get outfits
she's all kinds of stuff but my parents
wanted me to have a work ethic so they
would never buy me the doll because
they're ridiculously expensive and they
wanted me to be a good person rather
than happy so I never so you never got
you're obsessed with American Girl dolls
you never got more I never got one okay
well I like to make people's dreams come
true and that's the biggest false what
I've ever stated is not the case but
just for the sake of this I heard that
and I was like I want to I love Taylor
she's really funny she's really talented
she's a good person I want to correct
this it's Chicago by the way that's why
there's a siren every five minutes oh my
god okay
yeah someone they're going to arrest
someone who just ordered something
without cheese anyway I wanted to make
Terra's dreams come true so I went to
the American do you really yes I went to
the store I've been there before by the
way I've had my own experience I shot a
remote once where I got completely drunk
I bought an American cross oh and then I
got really trashed drinking wine in the
American girl restaurant in Los Angeles
look that up Conan American girl it's a
fun one if you want to see me really
trash talking to a doll but I got you a
choice you I got two dolls you get to
choose one and only one Oh baby yes so
I'm gonna make your dreams come true
right now here's your first option meet
Samantha Mary Parkington do you want to
hear about her she was born in 1895
which means she's dead she loves to read
her favorite book The Wizard of Oz she's
naive due to a sheltered life by the way
this is exactly how I dressed as a boy
yeah and that's a thick cap right there
she's rich and she lives with her
grandma you want to hold her for a
second
I don't want to get attached okay it's a
bit it's not a bit he's a bit for
Facebook no no you get to keep one of
these dolls I do one but you have to
make it's like a reality show and I'm
told yes
are you I have to hand won a rose all
right yeah basically there's one that
gets to stay with you and the other goes
all right so so she's gonna leave
temporarily and I want you to meet
there's like a weird dream I feel like I
over well Gotham's the weirdest dream
Conan O'Brien bought me a doll yeah it
sounds really creepy when you say it
that way yeah I'm your creepy
inappropriate dad figure here we go meet
kit kittredge born in 1923 she grew up
in the Depression era Cincinnati
depression I grew up in a depression but
not the Depression era as she's a tomboy
but she loves square dancing
oh my god Bravo what is wrong with you
look kit kittredge she's like oh I grew
up in Depression era Cincinnati and it
was nothing as bad as this alright so
anyway she's a tomboy which left square
dancing loves the country life and the
great outdoors she loves her father this
is an actual quote from the box loves
her father with or without a job yes but
it but it's so clearly like loves her
father with or without a job is she
still under and she's also codependent
she's trapped in a codependent
relationship with a man now hang on to
kit look at those those are great boots
I want this whole outfit yeah now here
comes the tricky part
you get to say hello don't you got to
keep one forever the other one will be
destroyed yeah I'm gonna feed it into
one of those mulching machines no no I
won't destroy it I'll do something with
it but one of them gets to come be with
you is it gonna be
I don't even forget her name what's your
name Samantha this is Samantha beeswax
and this is a kit kittredge which i know
it's hard and look they both want to be
with you I know I should be clear these
were like the two dolls everyone wanted
to be growing up I which means I relate
to neither of them okay there were other
ones that I related to more they had
glasses these two are like everyone
wanted to be kid not because of her
backstory but because she was really
cute Samantha's very pretty but she's
like rich or whatever but I think her
parents were kind of absent so there's
that
I feel more connected to this one I read
more of these books than I did of these
so who's it gonna be
I like this outfit better how long who
is it gonna be one life is gonna be very
happy and the other child will probably
turn to suit the other one I can't tell
you can't tell ya it involves hot lava
oh okay there's all stop lava okay I'm
gonna do
oh so hard their faces look similar I'm
genuinely having a difficult time
deciding okay pick me
I'm grew up in the depression but I have
never known real love yes I'm so sorry
no no it's okay she's she's crying
look she's crying okay maybe we'd knock
no no no I already picked you already
picked and you know what she wouldn't
want you now nope you imagine how
damaged this relationship would be a few
chose her I know I'm like the guy who
lose his wife and then a week later
comes back look she's gonna just go live
no oh she's gonna go live in this bush
there she's gonna remain this is so
bittersweet for me she can't even look
at you
by the way up through the Chicago area
and you want to adopt kit kittredge
she's hanging out in this shrubbery over
near the water tower I actually you know
what I'm not gonna do this to you okay
I'm gonna have did you just have her
waving goodbye that's so cruel
I found someone a good parent is gonna
love this doll just as much as you
Flula Borg yes yes you are now the proud
owner of is this depression-era kids
Kittridge face Cincinnati Ohio how did
you know I know all of the American Girl
places ice is incredible so you're happy
about this I am so relation right now
it's naughty you don't see you later
this is Vincent so see look everyone's
happy if this is a big thing okay that's
fine it is a big thing so you want to
open in your hometown of Erlangen yes
you want to open an American Girl store
yes yes I would pull my visas for all of
the plastics very nice very nice this I
think we're all happy that you're happy
and we got the box you're gonna get get
to keep the box and well once again
another siren here in Chicago city of
sirens again I've made people's dreams
come true and by again I mean for the
first time in my life by everybody